l'épidémie actuelle qui a peut-être
tendance à faire oublier d'autres crises
celle du sida par exemple 1,7 million de
personnes sont infectées chaque jour
dans le monde 170 mille français vivent
aujourd'hui avec le vih le sidaction qui
est à la fois l'association est
l'événement de lutte contre le sida est
fragilisée suite à cette crise sanitaire
en avril dernier l annulation du grand
week-end de mobilisation qui avait
permis par exemple de récolter 4 5
millions d'euros de dons l'an passé un
appel à la mobilisation est donc lancée
par l'association à l'occasion d'une
soirée une grande soirée proposée ce
soir sur france 2 on en parle avec
sandrine fourni et bonsoir
ben ça alors vous êtes la directrice du
pôle financement recherché association
pour le sidaction
déjà la lutte contre le sida est ce
qu'on peut dire qu'elle est réellement
menacé aujourd'hui oui tout à fait
d'abord il est évidemment important que
tout le monde se mobilise contre ce
nouveau virus
le corps n'a pour l'heure les je dirais
que les perspectives de deux vaccins
sont plutôt bien engagé de nombreuses et
c'est odieux
je crois que tout le monde tout un
chacun à se mobiliser pour se protéger
individuellement et collectivement
évidemment il faut pas oublier un autre
virus qui malheureusement basse très
actif en france qui est le vih toulon 6
milles 1 6200 contiennent contaminations
annuelles
il reste encore beaucoup à faire pour
notamment rendre le dépistage jeudi des
réflexes c'est très important
aujourd'hui parmi ces personnes
nouvellement diagnostiqués la moitié
n'avait jamais réalisé de test
un tiers de ces personnes sont arrivés
au diagnostic était déjà très affaibli
on veut vraiment nous avons des outils
pour ça ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui vous
redoutez qu'après cette crise sanitaire
d'autres crises émergent peut être des
choses que l'on a mis de côté pendant
sept se tendent coronavirus que d'autres
crises émerge après cette crise
sanitaire
évidemment c'est vrai alors c'est vrai
en france est d'ores et déjà le cas
pendant le film ans on a vu des
associations en première ligne pour
aller porter secours je veux dire mettre
à l'abri des personnes dont elle
s'occupait qui n'ont pas de logement
pendant sept manches confinement mais
aussi distribué des repas faire du
soutien psychologique ça a été l'impact
psychologique de cette crise n'est pas
encore bien mesuré mais je peux vous
dire que sur le terrain les associations
étaient présentes au bout du vide et
évidemment à au delà et ensuite la
capacité d'action a financé les 65
programmes de recherche en cours et sand
projet associatif en france et c'est
évidemment vous pouvez c'est très
important mais un coup dur importé
forcément à cette lutte c'est
l'annulation du week-end du sidaction
qui devait se dérouler en avril dernier
je le disais tout à l'heure un l'an
dernier le week-end avait permis de
récolter 4,5 millions d'euros de dons
donc c'est un sérieux coup dur
aujourd'hui qui est porté à cette lutte
oui même si nous connaissons de
différentes manières tout au long de
l'année évidemment ce week-end très
visible
chacun des médias vraiment aidé un
partenaire solide depuis plusieurs
années est très important c'est le cas
évidemment de thunes collectons tout au
long de l'année
donc on essaie aujourd'hui évidemment de
pouvoir rattraper un peu cela on
continuera ou là mais évidemment
multiplier les occasions de collecte je
lui dis c'est très important et c'est
encore malheureusement tout à fait mais
vous l'avez dire des dons qui peuvent se
faire tout au long de l'année pourquoi
justement c'est primordial de donner à
quoi servent ces dons que finance-t-il
alors ils financent de la recherche ne
pourront pas de la recherche qui
évidemment bénéficie à la lutte contre
le sida en particulier je pense à des
programmes qui sait mieux comprendre le
système immunitaire et vous comprenez
bien que ces programmes là le bénéficie
également à d'autres pathologies
notamment on voit bien que les essais
sur le coni d'aujourd'hui qui porte sur
les traitements évidemment porte
également sur un centre de traitement
on utilise un pays à genoux oui il ya
des ponts en fait pour la recherche et
on soutient
h mais aussi bien évidemment la
recherche plus globalement d'autres
pathologies
les actions associatives sont très
importantes aujourd'hui il faut vraiment
davantage cibler les actions sur des
populations particulièrement exposées je
pense aux aux actions qui vont vraiment
au devant des travailleuses du sexe des
personnes me demandent des personnes en
prison mais aussi les mais aussi contre
continuer la sensibilisation en
particulier auprès des jeunes qui
malheureusement on le voit connaissent
de moins gens bien moi qu'un le vih des
moyens de se protéger ses modes de
transmission a été alors tout de même ce
soir une soirée exceptionnelle sur
l'antenne de france 2 qui sera proposé
autour des comédies musicales autour de
line renaud c'est une soirée à qui est
proposée ce soir
tafer emprunte à fait inédit en fait
sans temps de me comédie musicale
revisité avec de nombreux invités
évidemment les danseuses du moulin rouge
du paradis latin gerets a invité pour
wii revisité par départ des tableaux
fait 100 ans et des communes et médical
qu'on a tous en tête aussi bien
historique notre dame
ça c'était très important de la
maintenir malgré l'annulation vous
l'avez dire le sidaction aussi besoin de
de ces moments de coup de projecteur oui
tout à fait c'est bien l'objectif et
séquences évidemment à nous et à nos
partenaires à la fois le groupe france
télévisions mais d'autres partenaires
médias et vous y participer aujourd'hui
qui renaît donc nous appel à dons tout
au long de la journée permettent
d'appeler le 110 le et sur sidaction
quant au mali elles appellent à lancer
que vous voulez lancer aux
téléspectateurs c'est n'oubliez pas le
sida il faut il faut encore se mobiliser
il faut se mobiliser il faut se protéger
il faut absolument
dès lors qu'on ait une vie sexuelle
active qu'on change de partenaire être
dépistées c'est surtout ça qu'il faut
réduire puisque lorsqu'on est traitée
tôt on met une bonne espérance de vie
aujourd'hui et on ne transmet plus le
bienvenu vih ont vraiment
responsabiliser et surtout il faut il
faut faire davantage d'efforts pour que
les jeunes soir qui sont dans
désintéresse puisqu'il nous n'entendons
plus l'écho médiatique tout au long de
l'année comme autrefois de deux voiles à
ce virus
il faut que les jeunes continuent à se
faire plaisir il faut évidemment qui
profitent du déconfinement mais surtout
surtout qu'ils gardent des réflexes très
anti tht et qui est qu'ils aient recours
au dépistage d'élan qu'ils ont une
bisexuelle et comment peut-on donner
justement dernière question aujourd'hui
est seulement aujourd'hui en appelant le
110 tout au long de l'année sur
sidaction.org et sinon vous pouvez pas
faire aussi un petit don de cinq amours
en comptant en d'abandon avec sur votre
téléphone portable au 92 110 des liens
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
sandrine fournier d'avoir été avec nous
mais je rappelle que vous êtes la
directrice du pôle financement recherché
association pour le sidaction ce rendez
vous à ne pas manquer ce soir 21h05 sur
france 2 une grande soirée musicale en
faveur de la lutte contre le sida